.
Im Kampf gegen das Coronavirus
steht Martin Bühler
im Kanton Graubünden
an vorderster Front.
Im Moment ist die Situation
jeden Tag wieder anders.
Und Sie selbst
sind von zu Hause ausgezogen?
Ja, zurzeit wohne ich
vorübergehend in Meiersboden,
in einem kleinen Studio.
Der Grund ist aber nicht, dass
ich Streit mit meiner Frau hätte,
sondern weil mir wichtig ist,
da ich so viel unterwegs bin
und mit vielen Menschen
Kontakt habe,
dass ich es nicht
in die Familie hineintrage.
Wie zieht ein Krisenchef im
Hintergrund der Pandemie die Fäden?
Wenn es Verdachtsfälle gibt,
müssen sie zu Hause bleiben.
Welche Hindernisse
stellen sich ihm in den Weg?
Gut, das ging in die Hose.
Und wie sehen seine Tage
im Ausnahmezustand aus?
Ich will nicht verhandeln,
sondern priorisieren.
Eine Chronologie über zwei Monate
in Zeiten von Corona.
Freitag, 6. März: Zivilschutz-
anlage Meiersboden in Chur.
Martin Bühler, Chef des Kantonalen
Führungsstabes in Graubünden,
kurz vor Beginn des Lagerapports.
Das Ziel ist nicht,
Sachen zu diskutieren,
sondern aufzunehmen, was es zu
diskutieren gibt und wer diskutiert.
Herr Bühler,
ist es das erste Mal,
dass Sie
einen solchen Ernstfall erleben?
Nein.
- Nicht?
Aber in dieser Grössenordnung
im Kanton,
was das Stabsaufgebot betrifft
und auch die vielen Involvierten,
das haben wir ausser bei Übungen
noch nie erlebt.
Aus allen Ämtern
haben sich Kaderleute versammelt.
Geschätzte Damen und Herren,
guten Morgen
zu diesem fünften Lagerapport.
Lage, Patrick?
Wie sieht die Lage
in der Schweiz aus?
Zurzeit gibt es 80 bestätigte Fälle,
bestätigt
durch das Referenzlabor in Genf.
Es gab einen ersten Todesfall
im Kanton Waadt.
Wie sehen wir die
wahrscheinlichste Lageentwicklung?
In einigen Tagen wird es
zu einem starken Anstieg
an Erkrankungen
aufgrund lokaler Übertragungen
kommen.
In einigen Wochen wird es
möglicherweise im Gesundheitswesen
zu personellen und
infrastrukturellen Engpässen kommen.
Die Verunsicherung in der
Bevölkerung wird weiter ansteigen.
Es ist mit direkten Auswirkungen auf
das öffentliche Leben zu rechnen.
Durch Hamsterkäufe
wird es vorübergehend
zu Lieferengpässen
in den Läden kommen.
Getroffene Massnahmen:
Ihr könnt sie lesen.
Ich will nur
zu den neuen etwas sagen.
Einerseits müssen wir
einen Überblick bekommen.
Deshalb wollen wir
ein Lagezentrum einrichten.
Welche Massnahmen
treffen Schulen, Gemeinden, etc.?
Gibt es Fragen?
"Schulen ist es untersagt,
Ausflüge oder Reisen ins Ausland
durchzuführen."
Für den Rest der Verwaltung
gilt nichts,
aber was bedeutet das
in der Konsequenz,
wenn wir ins Ausland müssen?
Entweder geschäftlich
oder ferienhalber.
Z.B. nächstes Wochenende in Mailand
shoppen gehen, da es günstig ist,
weil keine Leute da sind.
Will man hier
eine Empfehlung abgeben?
Es gibt keine Ausreise-
oder Einreisebeschränkungen,
weder vom Bund
noch von anderen Ländern.
Jeder kann persönlich entscheiden,
ob er in einem Corona-Land
einkaufen will.
Wenn wir alle so weit bringen,
mental von weiss
nach orange zu gehen -
wenn wir diese mentalen
Bereitschaftsstufen nehmen -
und sich zu überlegen,
was man zum Guten beitragen kann,
dann haben wir extrem viel erreicht.
Es bahnen sich
aussergewöhnliche Zeiten an.
Vorbereitungen laufen, den Arbeits-
alltag auf den Kopf zu stellen.
Alle Dienststellen sind beauftragt,
an ihrem BCM-Konzept zu arbeiten.
Es geht darum,
ob einzelne Mitarbeiter
von zu Hause aus arbeiten können.
Im Zusammenhang mit Corona
dürfen sie nicht ins Büro kommen.
Cool, vielen Dank.
Diese Voraussetzung muss
jetzt sichergestellt sein,
damit alle Dienststellen
diese Info haben.
Ganz herzlichen Dank, denn das
ist genau das, was wir brauchen,
um auf der Fachschiene
die Planung zu machen.
Seit Mitte Februar ist Martin Bühler
als Krisenchef im Einsatz.
Blenden wir zurück.
Dienstag, 25. Februar:
Drei Wochen
bevor die Wirtschaft durch den
Bundesrat praktisch stillgelegt wird,
begleiten wir Martin Bühler
zum ersten Mal.
Der 44-Jährige studierte Politikwis-
senschaft, Staats- und Völkerrecht.
In der Armee ist er Oberstleutnant
im Generalstab
des Kommandos für Spezialkräfte.
Er war Militärbeobachter
in Israel und im Balkan.
Seit 2016 ist er Leiter des
Amtes für Militär und Zivilschutz.
Jetzt ist er mehr gefordert denn je.
Dank eines Pandemieplanes sind
die Bündner aber gut vorbereitet.
Hier sieht man
die eingelagerten Schutzmasken.
Das sind medizinische Einwegmasken.
Zudem haben wir
vom Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz
die Möglichkeit bekommen,
für Notfälle
und für hohe Priorisierung
auch noch Masken
mit höherer Qualität zu bestellen.
Davon haben wir Gebrauch gemacht.
Das sind diese hier, nicht?
Genau.
Und das sind ...
Haben wir keine geöffnet?
Doch, die sind hier vorbereitet.
Das sind die Einwegschutzmasken.
Davon haben wir 500'000 Stück.
Die sind für eine Nutzung
von 2-3 Std. gedacht.
Freitag, 28. Februar:
Bundesrat Alain Berset
tritt vor die Medien.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt
haben sich in der Schweiz
laut Bundesamt für Gesundheit BAG
29 Menschen
mit dem Coronavirus angesteckt.
Deswegen haben wir
heute entschieden,
in der Sitzung von heute Morgen,
dass die Situation in der Schweiz
als besondere Lage einzustufen ist.
Gemäss Epidemiengesetz Artikel 6.
Wir haben auch entschieden,
Grossveranstaltungen mit mehr
als 1'000 Personen zu verbieten.
Diese Verordnung ist
seit heute Morgen 10 Uhr in Kraft.
Ich schicke dir eine E-Mail weiter.
Der Krisenchef und sein Stab reagie-
ren umgehend auf die neue Situation.
Z.B. hier:
Bühlers Team beantwortet schriftlich
eingehende Fragen
aus der Bevölkerung.
Es gibt Leute,
die enttäuscht sind,
dass sie ihre Veranstaltung
nicht durchführen können.
Aber es ist nun mal einfach so.
Aber im Allgemeinen
haben wir positive Anfragen
und die Leute sind froh,
dass wir ihnen sagen,
wie sie damit umgehen sollen.
Wir wollten nur anrufen und
erfahren, ob Sie etwas brauchen,
wie es Ihnen in der Quarantäne geht,
ob wir etwas für Sie tun können.
Zivilschützer sind in Kontakt
mit Menschen, die in Verdacht stehen,
sich mit dem Coronavirus
angesteckt zu haben.
Im Bündnerland
gibt es bisher zwei bestätigte Fälle.
Trotz vorhandenem Pandemieplan
läuft noch nicht alles reibungslos.
So gibt es z.B. keine
gemeinsame Kommunikationsstelle
für alle Departemente.
Bühler will das ändern.
Doch nicht alle Kaderleute
sind darauf vorbereitet.
Sie haben Mühe,
Kompetenzen abzugeben.
Es ist wichtig, dass die Menschen
Antworten auf ihre Fragen kriegen,
ohne suchen zu müssen.
Das ist das Ziel.
Jetzt geht es darum,
alles zu strukturieren,
u.a. die Kommunikation.
Dazu wollen wir
eine Kommunikationsstelle,
die ab Montag live geht.
Zuerst müssen wir wissen: Wo ist das
Problem? Und was will man erreichen?
So ganz klar ist das noch nicht.
Ich kann dir diesen Ablauf
jetzt nicht vorbeten.
Es braucht jetzt
einen offenen Geist, der sagt:
"Okay, einiges ist klar,
anderes ist unklar."
Wir müssen in einer
unklaren Situation versuchen,
ein möglichst synchronisiertes
System aufzubauen.
Du sagst jetzt aber: "Wir wissen es
noch nicht, wir bauen es auf."
Ich kam
mit einer anderen Erwartung her,
ich dachte,
die Situation sei anders.
Aber es ist gut,
dass wir es jetzt wissen.
Man gibt einen Teil
der Führungsverantwortung
als Dienststellenleiter,
Departement oder Regierungsrat ab.
Ich habe nach zwei Wochen
genug davon,
mit einem Fünferteam
oder Siebnerteam zu arbeiten.
Ich will, dass alle Departemente
und hochangesiedelten Stellen
die Last mittragen.
Ich könnte es mir
nächste Woche einrichten,
Montag, Dienstag und Donnerstag
hier zu sein
und mit Simon
seine Themen zu formulieren.
Mein Angebot ist, dass jemand
aus dem DVS am Montag hier ist
und in einer ersten Phase
beim Aufbau hilft,
damit die verschiedenen Bedürfnisse
abgebildet werden können.
Gut.
Vielen Dank.
Nein, nein, jetzt hören wir auf
und gehen essen.
Vielen Dank, wirklich.
Cool, danke.
Ist das gut für dich?
- Ja, alles bestens.
Es ist ihm gelungen,
die Leute ins Boot zu holen.
Ich habe einen solchen Kopf.
Die Informationen
der letzten zehn Tage
speichern sich im Hinterkopf ab.
Man merkt gar nicht,
dass man sie speichert.
Es geht um irgendein Thema
und plötzlich flitzen sie nach vorne
und sorgen für Chaos.
Dann muss man
einfach mal Luft holen.
Hast du nie Rauch im Kopf?
Musst du nie kurz raus
und den Kopf auslüften?
Doch, doch, das passiert mir auch.
Es ist jetzt einfach, wie es ist,
und man versucht zu funktionieren.
Zu sagen, es sei nicht belastend,
wäre nicht wahr,
aber ... ja.
Oberhalb der Kantine
dieser Zivilschutzanlage
hat Martin Bühler Anfang März
eine kleine Wohnung bezogen.
Eine frühzeitige Massnahme zum Schutz
seiner Frau und der drei Kinder.
Das ist ...
... das Studio.
Und der Grund, warum ich
hierhergekommen bin, war einerseits,
dass ich so sicher sein kann,
meine Familie nicht anzustecken,
weil ich viel unterwegs bin.
Meine Frau arbeitet, sie sorgt
gleichzeitig für die Kinder,
und wir müssen einfach sicher sein,
dass es funktioniert.
Als ich noch zu Hause war,
haben wir aber auch gemerkt,
besonders in der ersten Phase,
dass ich zu Hause mehr Stress
als Ruhe verbreitet habe.
Wir fanden es dann besser,
wenn ich mich
auf die Arbeit konzentrieren kann
und wir zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt
wieder mehr Familienleben haben.
Haben Sie persönliche Gegenstände
mitgenommen?
Ich habe nicht viel mitgenommen.
Ich wollte Krafttraining machen und
habe diese zwei Hanteln mitgenommen.
Das Training war, diese von Fideris
hierherzufahren und hochzutragen.
Seither haben sie Ruhe -
und ich auch.
Und persönliche Dinge
von der Familie?
Ich habe von meinen Töchtern
Zeichnungen bekommen.
Was steht da auf den Zeichnungen?
"Lieber Papa, ich vermisse dich
und ich hoffe, dass
der Coronavirus bald wieder weg ist
und du wieder zurückkommen kannst."
"Ich habe dich
sehr, sehr, sehr gern. Deine Maria."
Und das ist sie, glaube ich.
Sonntag, 8. März:
Schloss Haldenstein.
Bühler hat den Krisenstab einberufen.
Mittlerweile gibt es in der Schweiz
gemäss Angaben des BAG
428 Corona-Fälle.
Zwei Menschen mit COVID-19
sind gestorben.
In Norditalien
ist die Situation ausser Kontrolle.
Die Zahlen: In Italien
wurden 5'061 positiv getestet.
Von diesen 5'000
sind gerundet 2'700
hospitalisiert worden,
und von diesen 2'700
sind 570 auf der IPS.
Also wenn das eintrifft,
sind wir hoffnungslos überfordert.
Machen wir uns keine Illusionen,
es gibt keinen Grund, warum
das bei uns nicht passieren soll.
Wir können es nur verzögern.
Wir müssen es verlangsamen.
V.a. bei den Altersheimen.
Ich bitte dich, das morgen
sauber aufbereitet zu bringen.
Das ist matchentscheidend, um die
Eventualplanungen zu präzisieren.
Dazu müssten wir wissen,
wie lange es dauert.
Wie lange ist die Vorlaufzeit,
bis wir Armeeunterstützung bekommen?
Und was haben sie zu bieten?
Es gibt das Spitalbataillon.
- Wie viel Mann sind das?
Im Bataillon sind zwischen 500 und
900 Personen, je nach Bataillon.
Ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt
die Gesuche stellen.
Unbedingt.
Ich habe sie vorbereitet,
ich bringe sie morgen zum Rapport.
Jetzt müssten wir sagen,
wir brauchen Betreuer und Sanitäter,
zuerst vom Zivilschutz,
die eine erste Welle übernehmen.
Und dann holen wir die Armee,
wenn wir sie kriegen.
Gut, vielen Dank.
Donnerstag, 12. März:
unterwegs ins Misox.
Das Tal in Südbünden
grenzt an den Kanton Tessin.
Dort wurden Schulen, Kinos, Sport-
zentren und Nachtclubs geschlossen.
Mit 180 Infizierten
und zwei Todesfällen
liegt die Sonnenstube der Schweiz
weit über dem kantonalen Schnitt.
Jetzt könnte es sein, dass Dinge,
die im Tessin eingeschränkt sind,
aber im Misox noch nicht,
dazu führen,
dass sich die Leute mehr bewegen
und ins Misox reisen,
und dadurch
entsteht das Potenzial ...
... eine Erhöhung des Potenzials
für Ansteckungen.
In Südbünden wollen viele Gemeinden
die verschärften Massnahmen
des Tessins übernehmen.
In den restlichen Gebieten
Graubündens
will man vorläufig
keine strengeren Vorschriften.
Bühler trifft sich in Roveredo
mit den Präsidenten
der Gemeinden des Misox.
Auf der anderen Seite der Berge
ist die Situation anders als hier.
Ich bin hier,
um eine gemeinsame Lösung zu finden.
Man muss nicht darüber diskutieren,
was zu tun wäre.
Ich will dieselben verschärften
Massnahmen wie das Tessin.
Wenn wir die Tessiner Massnahmen
einführen, gibt das ein Chaos.
Ich mache, was ich will,
auch zum Wohle meiner Gemeinde.
Die anderen können
für sich selber schauen. Finito.
Die Situation ist angespannt.
Questo que posso offrire ...
Bühler versucht zu vermitteln:
Einer seiner Mitarbeiter
könne die Misoxer unterstützen.
Er werde helfen, einen
gemeinsamen Führungsstab aufzubauen.
Schlussendlich akzeptieren die
Anwesenden die Idee des Krisenchefs.
(Radio) Nach dem Entscheid der USA
sind an den europäischen Börsen
die Kurse erneut eingebrochen.
Damit zu den aktuellen Börsendaten.
Sind Sie zufrieden mit dem Resultat?
Was soll ich sagen?
Wir sind auf den Weg gekommen,
aber es ist uns nicht gelungen,
explizit Einigkeit hinzukriegen.
Es ist uns nicht gelungen,
eine gemeinsame Lösung
zur Umsetzung zu finden.
Das macht die Kommunikation
in dieser Phase schwierig.
Ist es nicht auch anstrengend
für Sie, wenn Sie merken,
dass Sie viel diskutieren und
Überzeugungsarbeit leisten müssen?
Klar, es ist anstrengend.
Ich bin jetzt
aus dieser Sitzung rausgekommen,
wir haben eine schwierige Situation,
die Gemeindepräsidentinnen und
-präsidenten stehen unter Druck,
auch von der Bevölkerung.
Mir schien schon,
dass die Emotionen hochgingen,
aber niemand wollte nicht,
dass wir eine Lösung finden.
Die Gemeinde Mesocco
am Südfuss des San Bernardino.
Martin Bühler
will hier Zivilschützer besuchen,
die in einem Altersheim
Dienst leisten.
Hier haben sie
die Massnahmen umgesetzt.
Es herrscht Besuchsverbot.
Das Besuchsverbot gilt aber für alle,
selbst für den Krisenchef.
Es bleibt ihm nichts anderes übrig,
als eine schriftliche Mitteilung an
seine Zivilschützer zu hinterlassen.
Gut, das ging in die Hose.
Sie sind gar nicht reingekommen.
- Nein.
Das ist blöd für Sie als Chef,
wenn Sie nachschauen wollen.
Ich hätte mich anmelden sollen.
Das war wohl mein Fehler.
Ciao, Christian. Grazie tanto.
Sonderregeln zwischen den Kantonen
und Dispute zwischen Gemeinden
wie im Misox.
Drei Tage später verordnet
der Bundesrat eine Massnahme,
die für alle gilt: eine weitgehende
Stilllegung der Wirtschaft.
Montag, 16. März:
Bundesrätin Simonetta Sommaruga
gibt die Hiobsbotschaft bekannt.
Ausser Lebensmittelgeschäften,
Apotheken und Drogerien
müssen alle Verkaufsläden schliessen.
Der Bundesrat hat entschieden,
die Situation zu einer
ausserordentlichen Lage zu erklären.
Die Regelung gilt ab Mitternacht
und dauert vorerst bis 19. April.
Damit haben wir in der ganzen
Schweiz einheitliche Regeln.
Jetzt muss ein Ruck
durch unser Land gehen.
Mittwoch, 18. März:
unterwegs ins Engadin.
Die Schweiz verzeichnet an diesem Tag
laut BAG über 6'000 Infizierte.
50 Menschen
starben bisher am Coronavirus.
Seit einem Monat
kämpft der Krisenchef
gegen die sich ausbreitende Pandemie.
Es ist nicht so,
dass alles rund läuft und ruhig ist.
Überhaupt nicht.
Aber im Moment
hat man noch das Gefühl,
wenn irgendwo
ein Konfliktherd entsteht,
wird man ihn in einigermassen nütz-
licher Frist in den Griff bekommen.
Ankunft in der Truppenunterkunft
in S-chanf.
Martin Bühler trifft sich
mit Offizieren der Armee.
Sein Gesuch ans Militär
um Unterstützung war erfolgreich.
Grüezi.
Hallo. Martin Bühler.
Mich würde interessieren,
was ihr
als euer Leistungsprofil seht,
was ihr macht
und v.a. was ihr nicht macht.
Wir haben einerseits den Spit Sdt,
den Spitalsoldaten.
Der Spitalsoldat
ist dazu ausgebildet,
die Grundpflege von Patienten
in stabilen Situationen
sicherzustellen.
Jawohl.
Dann haben wir unsere Transportzüge,
Patiententransporte.
Dort können wir selbstständig
stabile Patienten transportieren.
Wir können Fahrer, Beifahrer plus
einen oder zwei Begleiter stellen.
Wiederholen Sie das bitte?
Können wir uns duzen?
Ich bin Martin. Wenn das okay ist.
Tipptopp.
- Gut.
Also, wie haben
Fahrer plus Beifahrer
und ein bis zwei Begleitpersonen.
Und unsere Leute können
im Schichtbetrieb arbeiten.
Wir zahlen dem Spital nichts
für die Verpflegung.
Und ebenfalls nichts für die
ganze Inkonvenienz-Entschädigung,
z.B. Wäsche.
Das wird alles
über das Spital geführt.
Mit dem Leistungskatalog der Armee
geht es dann zum nächsten Treffen.
Bühler hat Spitaldirektoren
und Kaderleute des Grenzwachtkorps
eingeladen.
Das ist in etwa das
Leistungsspektrum des Detachements,
des Spit Bat 5,
worüber wir verhandeln können.
Sollen sie kommen? Wann
sollen sie kommen? Wer kriegt was?
Bei stabilen Patienten ist
die Beurteilung eher schwierig.
Und bei der Grundpflege
wird es auch schwierig.
Wenn ich den Stand der Dinge
anschaue, brauche ich Sie nicht.
Im Moment. Aber das kann
in vier Wochen anders aussehen.
... gerade in den etwas populis-
tischen Ländern wie Österreich,
die jetzt sagen: "Italienische
Staatsbürger müssen dort bleiben."
Ich sehe das immer
als unrealistisch.
Das hätte ich
vor einer Woche nicht gesagt.
Und wenn das eintritt,
bräuchten wir wohl schlagartig
jeder ein eigenes Bataillon,
um das Spital weiterzuführen.
Von diesen 154 Personen
sind 117 aus dem Veltlin.
Sie können es sich ja vorstellen,
das sind mehr als 50 %.
Und wenn jetzt in der Nacht
die Grenzen gesperrt würden,
gäbe das ein grosses Problem.
Wir werden eine Lösung finden.
- Das ist für uns wichtig.
Der Armeeeinsatz in den Spitälern
ist also momentan nicht notwendig.
Sorgen machen den Spitaldirektoren
aber die Grenzübergänge,
die nachts
geschlossen werden sollen.
Unser Personal wird in Zukunft
extrem belastet und ausgelastet.
Ich verstehe nicht ...
Wir müssen 24-Std.-Dienste
mit Überbelastung fahren.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum die Grenze
nachts nicht besetzt sein kann.
Dass sie zu ist,
ist für mich kein Problem.
Aber es kann doch nicht sein,
dass man sagt,
wir sollen
mit unseren Mitarbeitern hochfahren,
sie sollen nicht
nach Italien heimfahren ...
Unsere Mitarbeiter
wären dazu sogar bereit.
Aber es kann doch nicht sein ...
Polizei, Militär, Zivilschutz
wurden aktiviert.
Aber ich habe noch nicht verstanden,
warum die Grenze
nachts nicht besetzt wird.
Das Grenzwachtteam
dürfen wir zwar filmen,
nicht jedoch
ihren Originalton verwenden.
Man habe zu wenig Leute,
um alle Übergänge
rund um die Uhr zu besetzen,
sagt die Kaderfrau der Grenzwacht.
Dann finden die Anwesenden
eine Lösung.
Die Zollübergänge werden
durch zusätzliches Wachpersonal
auch nachts besetzt.
Damit kann das Spitalpersonal aus
Italien nach der Arbeit heimkehren.
Es müssen Grenzwache, Polizei
oder Zivilschutz dabei sein.
Das machen wir so.
Und dann versuchen wir,
diesen Plan aufzustellen.
Wieder ist ein Problem vom Tisch.
Bühler trifft täglich viele Menschen.
Die Gefahr ist gross, dass er selber
mit dem Coronavirus angesteckt wird.
Ein paar Tage danach.
Aus Sicherheitsgründen findet das
Wiedersehen per Videokonferenz statt.
Was ist mit Ihrem Team?
Ein Zivilschützer
wurde positiv getestet.
Deswegen mussten wir
einige Massnahmen ergreifen.
Zur Sicherheit des Stabs
halten wir den Rapport
nicht mehr im Plenum ab,
schon seit mehr als einer Woche,
sondern wir machen
eine Telefonkonferenz.
Am Telefon sagten Sie, dass Sie
eine Erkrankung mit dem Virus
bei sich selbst nicht ausschliessen.
Stimmt das?
Wenn man so viel unterwegs
und in Kontakt mit Menschen ist,
auch wenn man versucht,
sich an die Regeln zu halten,
besteht natürlich die Chance,
dass man sich ansteckt.
Aber vom Gefühl her denke ich nicht,
dass ich mich angesteckt habe.
Ich bin gesund,
ich habe kein Kratzen im Hals.
Ich bin etwas müde, weil die Tage
lang sind. Aber das gehört dazu.
Donnerstag, 16. April:
nach vier Wochen Stillstand.
Bisher starben laut Angaben des BAG
über 1'100 Menschen am Coronavirus.
Aber es gibt auch gute Nachrichten.
Die Ausbreitung des Coronavirus
wurde gebremst.
Unsere Spitäler
sind zurzeit nicht überlastet.
Das ist eine gute Nachricht.
Und es folgt gleich
eine weitere gute Nachricht:
Nun können wir
erste Lockerungen vorsehen.
Samstag, 18. April:
Noch immer
ist die Zivilschutzanlage bei Chur
der Wohnsitz des Krisenchefs.
Sein am Coronavirus erkrankter
Zivilschützer ist wieder gesund.
Martin Bühler
blieb es die ganze Zeit hindurch.
In den ersten zwei Monaten
des Ausnahmezustandes
habe er die Zusammenarbeit
mit allen Beteiligten geschätzt.
Doch ganz zufrieden ist er nicht:
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass
irgendetwas total in die Hose ging.
Bis jetzt ist das nicht der Fall
auf unserer Ebene und bei der
Stabsarbeit, die wir gemacht haben.
Aber es gibt etwas Altbekanntes:
die Kommunikation.
Sowohl nach innen
als auch nach aussen.
Gerade weil wir
so viele Akteure haben,
so viele Erwartungen und
unterschiedliche Wahrnehmungen.
Das nehme ich als eine
der grössten Herausforderungen mit.
Wie wir das organisieren wollen,
daran können wir noch arbeiten.
Wissen Sie schon konkret, wann Sie
zu Ihrer Familie zurückkehren können?
Nein, und es ist
nicht nur wegen der Krankheit,
sondern auch
wegen der Intensität der Arbeit.
Ich habe mich entschieden,
mich darauf zu konzentrieren.
Ich weiss es noch nicht,
aber ich freue mich darauf.
Ich bin gespannt
auf den Verlauf der Lockerungen.
Wenn es gut läuft,
will ich ab Ende Monat wieder
von zu Hause aus zur Arbeit kommen.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Alexandra Duttweiler - 2020